foreign
today we will take you through a hands
of lab demo how we can use lstm model
for forecasting in machine learning
before we start I hope this screen is
clearly visible and the audio is fine if
yes please type in yes if there are any
issues do let us know in the chat
section so that we can resolve them
let's wait for some more minutes to let
other people join
until then let me tell you guys that we
have regular updates on multiple
Technologies if you are a tech geek in a
continuous hunt for the latest
technological Trends then consider
getting subscribed to our YouTube
channel and press that Bell icon to
never miss any update from Simply love
great I think we can get started so in
today's session we will discuss what
lstm model is and moving ahead we will
discuss what RNN is after that we will
see types of gates in lstm model after
covering types we will see some
applications of lstm models and at the
end we will do a hand Supply demo of
gold price prediction using lstm model
before we move on to the programming
part let's discuss what lscm model is
and positive further for the same so
what is lstm long short term memory lstm
is a type of recurrent neural network
that can capture long-term dependencies
in sequential data lstm order are able
to process and analyze sequential data
such as time series text and speech they
use a memory cell and engage to control
the flow of information allowing them to
selectively retain or discard
information as needed and thus avoid the
vanishing gradient problems that plagues
traditional RNN lstm are widely used in
various applications such as natural
language processing speech recognition
and Time series
so moving ahead we will see what is RNN
RNN are a type of neural network that
are designed to process sequential data
they can analyze data with temporal
Dimensions such as time series speech
and text RNN can do this by using hidden
state passed from one timestamp to the
next the hidden state is updated at each
timestamp based on the input and the
previous hidden state
R and N are able to capture short-term
dependency in sequential data
but they struggle with the capturing
long-term dependencies
so after understanding what is RNN
moving forward let's see types of gates
in lscm model
so there are three types of gates in
lstm models the input gate the forget
gate and the output gate the input gate
controls the flow of information into
the memory cells the forget gate
controls the flow of information out of
the memory cells the output gate
the lstm model into the output
so the input gate the input gate decides
which information to store in the memory
cell it is trained to open when the
input is important and the close when it
is not the second one is the forget gate
the forget gate decides which
information to discard from the memory
cell it is trained to open when the
information is no longer important and
closed when it is the third one is the
output gate the output gate is
responsible for deciding when
information to use for the output of the
lstm it is trained to open when the
information is important and close when
it is not the gates in an lstm are
trained to open and close based on the
input and the previously done state this
allows the lstm to selectability retain
or discard information making it more
effective at capturing long-term
dependencies so moving forward let's see
what are the application of lstm models
long short term memory lstm is highly
effective RNN that has been utilized in
various applications so here are few
well-known lstm application the first
one is language simulation language
support Vector machine lstm have been
utilized for natural language processing
tasks such as language modeling machine
translation and text summarization by
understanding the relationship between
words in a sentence they can be trained
to construct meaningful and
grammatically correct sentences the
second one is voice recognition lstm
have been utilized for speech
recognition tasks such as speech to text
to text transcription and command
recognition they may be taught to
recognize pattern in speech and match
them to appropriate text the third one
is sentiment analysis lstm can be used
to classify text sentiment as positive
negative or neutral by learning the
relationship between words and their
associate sentiment the fourth one is
time series prediction lstm can be used
to predict future values in a Time
series by learning the relationship
between past values and future values
the fifth one is video analysis LCM can
be used to analyze video by learning the
relationship between frames and their
associate actions object and the scenes
and the last one is handwriting
recognition lstm can be used to
recognize handwriting by learning the
relationship between images of
handwriting and the corresponding text
so after seeing application of lstm so
let's move to the programming part so
first we will open command prompt to
write command to open jupyter notebook
so here we will write
Jupiter
notebook
Jupiter notebook is open this is the UI
of Jupiter notebook so here we will go
new python 3.
so this is the python kernel UI of The
jupyter Notebook
so now
so first we will import some major
libraries of python which will help us
in analyzing the data and prediction and
all okay so here we will write import
numpy
S and B
second import
pandas
as PD
third one is import
matplotlib
dot Pi plot
as PLT
fourth one is import
antly
dot Express
as
okay so these are some you know basic
libraries
so like from
and scalan
Dot
pre-processing
reprocessing import
Max
scalar
okay then from
skill learn
Dot
model
selection
import
train
test
split
this is used for like dividing the data
into training and the testing
okay
split
then from
scale on
dot matrix
import
solute
percentage
okay then some import
tensorflow
as TF
then from
Keras
import
model
and from
here as
dot layers
port
dance
drop out
then from Keras
dot layers
import the major one lstm
is
so we are doing we will do the goal
prediction okay we have the data from
2020 okay we have data from 2013 to 2023
like
okay there is one address
okay this is Keras
yeah so I will change to
gold
prediction
using
lstm okay
let's say name it
yeah
so first number is a python Library used
for working with that is it also has a
function for working in the domain of
linear algebra and matrices it is an
open source project and you can use it
freely numpy stand for numerical python
the second one is by pandas panda is a
software Library written for the Python
programming language for data
manipulation and Analysis in particular
it offers data structure an operation
for manipulating numerical tables and
The Time series
and now matplotlib for Python and its
numerical extension number Matt broadly
is a cross platform data visualization
and graphical charting package as a
result it presents a strong open source
suitable for Matlab the api's
application programming interfaces for
matplotlib allow programmers to
incorporate graphs into GUI applications
okay then
there is SQL and scikit-learn so psychic
learn is a free software machine
learning library for the Python
programming language teachers various
classification regression and clustering
algorithm including support Vector
machines random Forest gradient boosting
k-means and dbsc here and is designed to
interrupt
Incorporated with python numerical and
scientific libraries like numpy and
sci-fi
okay
then we have dance
a dense layer is a layer that is deeply
connected with its preceding layer which
means the neurons of the layers are
connected to every neuron of its
preceding layer this layer is most
commonly used layer in artificial neural
networks okay
then there is lstm
okay lstm stands for long short term
memory layer
you know all we we have discussed in the
starting of the video what is lstm what
is RNN and how types of lstm and some
application okay so LST stands for the
long short term memory layer which
created in 1997 this layer use available
constant and runtime Hardware to gain
the most optimized performance where we
can choose the various implementation
that is pure tensorflow or CU DNN based
okay so now what is tensorflow
tensorflows are free and open source
software library for machine learning
and artificial intelligence it can be
used across a range of tasks but has a
particular focus on training and
interface of deep neural network
okay so moving forward we will import
our data set
so for the reading data set we will
write DF equals to PD Dot
read underscore CSV
okay
then here we will let gold
price
dot CSV
okay so this data set goal price data
set you can download this result from
the description box below
okay
data set is loaded so now we will see
the overview of the data set so here we
will add DF press enter
so from 2022 like you know end of the
year of like
2022 till from the 2013.
okay
so as you can see the data set includes
daily gold prices information including
daily open and high and low prices and
the final price of each day along with
the volume transaction and the price
changes in Easton okay like price open
high low volume charge change percent
okay so let's see now data set basic
information
okay what I will do I will for the
better visuals I will
here I will write DF Dot
input
yes so
here all the variables are stored as
object okay date price open high low
volume or change percentage okay normal
count total value is 2583
okay memory uses 141.4 cubic
okay so now moving forward
let's do some data preparation okay
feature subject selection since we will
not use the volume and change percent
features to predict price we will drop
these two column or features you can say
okay so for dropping them we will write
here DF dot drop
volume
okay
then
change percent
then axis
equals to 1
is
equals to true
okay press enter
so
okay there is one error
volume not found in axis
okay we will is there only I guess
okay V is capital here
let's see the data set
see now the we have dropped these two
column volume and change percentage data
price open high and low
got it
so now here we will do some you know
transforming data and all so data
features is stored as object in the data
frame as you already know
see this object
so first we remove
uh node will not remove right now so to
increase the speed of calculation we
convert its data type to date time and
then sort this feature in ascending
order okay
so for that I will write here
it
goes to PD 2.2
date time
then DF
okay then DF dot sort
values
y equals to
date
then ascending
equals to true
is
true
then I will write TF dot reset
D is capital here
is
[Music]
okay press enter
so
so now what we will do I will write here
number of columns num columns
it was shown
DF Dot columns
dot drop
this state
then DF
some calls
equals to DF
dot replace
comma
here I will add colon
then
Rejects
question
true
okay then TF
num calls
equals to DF
Dot as
type
code 64.
okay
here
right press enter
okay this place the spelling is strong
mistake
capital
let's see is Captain
yeah
so the sign this one
this sign
I'll get this comma
sign is redundant in the data set so
first we remove it from the entire data
set and then change the data type of the
numerical variable to float
okay
so
enter yeah
okay
so now we will do here
so now we will see DF dot hat
Center
why head is used
so head is used for like showing only
top five rows of the data set
if you want to see the last five rows so
you can type here tail instead of head
or what if you want to see the top 10
rows so here you can write 10. okay 0 to
9 10.
right
so now date is changed into this
and descending order ascending order
okay
so now we will see the duplicates
so checking duplicates for that we have
to write
duplicate
zero there are no duplicate samples in
the data feature
okay then checking missing values so for
that we have to write DF dot is null
foreign
now what I will do
so now we will visualize the gold price
history data okay
by making
graph
so here we will write
figure equals to
PX dot line
the pi equals to DF Dot
price
question
Dot
update
date plan
traces
the line
now
color
should be
okay then figure Dot
update
layout
then X
axis
title equals to
date
comma
y axis
title
was to
price
comma then
oh
text okay we don't require this
it should be gold
those
data
then
comma y
0.95
then
X
X should be
0.5
then
X anchor
is Center
then
bye
anchor
y anchors
this atop
okay
come on then here we will add plot
BG color
rgba
two five five
comma two two three comma zero comma
zero point nine
okay
so as you can see the gold price data
graph
okay from 2013 to 2022
okay
so now what we will do we will split
data to training and test sets Okay so
there is one thing since we cannot train
on future data and time series data so
we should not divide the time series
data randomly okay like how much
percentage to give to training set
testing set like that n times series
splitting the testing set is always
later than the trading side okay so we
considered the last year of for testing
and the everything else for the training
got it I'm repeating again so
here the thing is that
since we cannot train on future data and
Time series
data okay so we should not divide the
time series data randomly and time
series splitting testing set is always
later than the training set so that we
will consider the last year for the
testing and the everything else for the
training
okay I will make a graph so from that
graph you will understand easily
okay so here I will write test
thighs question
Okay so
test size
also DF
dot date dot DT Dot ER equals sequence 2
0 2 2
okay
test
size
so here as you can see the test size is
260.
okay so now we will make a graph
of gold price like training how much is
for training how much is for testing
plot okay so for that I will write PLT
dot figure
then because size
equals to
15 comma 6
comma DPI equals to 150.
bigger than PLT Dot
RC params
access
comma
Edge color
was to White
okay
take
don't come here
the face color
question
yellow
okay then pld.rc
says
comma Edge color
equals to White
to C on
it will be good
then PLT Dot Plot
then DF Dot
date
test
let's go
guys
comma
DF dot price
then
underscore size
comma color
equals to
black
LW equals to 2.
okay
copy it for these
testing set
as well as the red
Small Change
now what we will do we will set the
title and all
title
gold price
then
and test
so after that
the minerals at the font size
PLT dot X label
and
date
comma
font size
to 12.
and PLT dot y level
and here I've read price
font size
12 only
so then PLT dot Legend
training set
comma
test okay
[Music]
test set
okay
then I would like the location
equals to
upper
left
position equals to
this is
size
okay then PLT dot grid
hello
question
White
then
PLT Dot
so this is the graph so this black color
graph is for the training set and this
red color graph is for testing set got
it
okay this is from the data only data set
we have
and this is the date price
okay date and time maybe I have to write
here or years maybe
okay so instead of date I will write
here
what should I write
okay
now it's good here
so after splitting in two day training
and the testing what we will do we will
do now data scaling okay since we aim to
predict price only based on historical
data so we have to scale the price using
uh using what we already know we have
like min max scalar
so we will do from that to avoid what
intensive computations okay so data
scaling now we will do data scaling so
here I will write a scalar
equals to
min
Max
scalar
okay
so we don't have to write again and
again min max scalar now we can write a
scalar equals to dot bit
DF dot price
values Dot
D shape
minus 1 comma 1.
okay
so min max scale is loaded so first we
will do
so now what we will do we will
restructure the data and create the
sliding windows
so the use of Prior time steps to break
the next time step is called the sliding
window okay so in this way what we can
do the time series data can be expressed
as supervised learning so we can do this
by using previous time steps as input
variables and use the next time step as
the output variable so the number of
previous step is called the window bit
here which we set window with 360.
therefore extend and X text will be
nested list containing list of 60
timestamp prices okay now listen
carefully y train and Y test are also
list of the gold prices containing the
next day's gold price correspond to each
list in the extend and the X Tax
okay so here we will set window
size equals to what what I said 60.
okay
press enter
now
training set
so train
theta equals to TF Dot
price
test
size
then train
data equals to scalar
Dot
transform
train
data Dot
values Dot
reshape
that
-1
comma 1. okay
press enter
now
X strain
array
then y train
okay so for I in
range
window
size comma
alien train
data
okay so X string
dot append
train data
I minus
I comma 0.
okay
then y
train dot append
10 data
I comma 0
okay
so this is for the training and now we
will do the or the testing data
as theta equals to TF
Dot
price
test size
the
okay then test
data question
Dot
transform
test data Dot
values dot b shape
S1
comma 1.
okay
then again for this
test
was to blank at a then y
s t equals to this
okay so for I and range
windows
size
comma
test data
test Dot band
minus 60
then I comma 0.
okay
then y
test dot band
test data
then I comma zero
yeah
for the training and the testing is done
let me check okay everything is fine
so now what we will do we will do
convert data into numpy arrays okay
so the thing is that now X Jane and X
this are nested list okay two Dimension
list and Y train is the one Dimensions
list
so we need to convert them to numpy
arrays with a higher Dimension which is
the data format accepted by the
tensorflow when the training the neural
network
let's start with that converting data
into numpy arrays so we will write X
train
equals to NP Dot array
X
chain
okay
and X
test
equals to
NP
Dot
array
test okay then why
let's train
equals to NP dot array
then y train
and y underscore test
we Dot
array
y test
okay
and we will write X
train
equals to NP dot C shape
ducks
train comma
next trend
dot shape
chain Dot
shape
test equals to
NP dot reshape
test comma
X
test dot shape
test
dot shape
one
and
question
and reshape
y
trained
come
S1 comma 1
then y test
equals to
NP dot V shape
then y
test comma
okay
testorship
text
tape
there is an errors so
let me debug
okay list object has no attribute shape
possible
copy it and paste it
again
mirror
k
Test X strain X test
white train and whitest
into
this email is coming
okay so let me debug this error
it was an error in this okay
so
now
what I will do I will print the shape
print
strain
shape
okay comma X strain
let me copy it
and print it four times
a train
Ed
a test okay
then here again why
X
best
y test
first let me do this okay see so there
are like this much of rows and columns
present in uh training and the test is
set
so now finally let's create a lstm
network okay we will build an lstm
Network which is a type of RNN the
current neural network designed to solve
Vanishing gradient problem like
forecasting and all okay
so for that let me write DF
fine
model
okay input
one
let's do input
shape
that's true
window
size
come on
equals to
lstm
done
says
so
true
but
then x equals to
drop out
0.2
plus 2
lstm
let's do 64.
comma return
expenses
true
x equals to
drop out
about
and zero point
two
X
okay
then x equals to lstm
this will be
64.
X
then x equals to
drop out
0.2 X
is capital
now
where I will write x equals to dance
you know the dense layer now we
discussed in the starting
activation
soft Max
thenx
then DNN
output
pursue tense
and model
inputs will be
put one
comma output
outputs equation
DNN
output
okay
then model Dot
compile
laws
assume
mean
when
error
comma optimizer
let's do
another
then model dot summary
and return
okay
then we have to define the model model
equals to Define
model
okay
then history
question model dot bit
X strain
comma y train
comma epochs
will be 150
comma batch
size should be
32 and the validation
spent
plus 2 0.1
then verbose
equals to 1.
okay now press enter
okay there is functional object has no
okay this is a spelling mistake
OKAY Model Model history
yes okay it's okay model.fit got a
validation okay spelling mistake
so sorry for this valid day
okay so it will be run till like 150 a
box
okay
so it will take like
it will
156 okay
so it will take a little bit time
until 158 will be low oh
after this we will do model evaluation
and then we will visualizing the result
after prediction okay
what the model will perform
it will take little bit time it's just
17 it will go till 150.
so we have to wait for this
this is all the laws and it will take
the accuracy and all
it will take a little bit up
okay 22
after this we will add the model
Evolution we will see the you know
the accuracy the test map the test loss
all the things like that
okay
and after that we will visualize the
result
training and the testing purpose
so okay I will get back to you when it
will be done
so till like 108 it's done still some 40
42 are left
so let's wait for some more time okay
it will be done then after that we will
what we will do we will visualize the
results and first we will do model
evaluation and then we will visualize
the result
okay in model evaluation we will see the
accuracy test accuracy the test map the
test loss
okay
then we will predict
the results
after that visualization result
like what's the actual and the predicted
price values okay on on using the same
chart
done one one two
you can download this data set from the
description box below
okay
and if you need this whole code you can
comment down for the same
if you need this whole code
okay I will make a PDF and I will
put in the description box if you need
this whole code
okay Christine
something more
I hope you guys understand till here if
you have any doubt you can you ask in
the comment section
okay any sort of question regarding to
Python and machine learning you can ask
in the comment section
what I expect will you
expert will help you out there okay
30 more
okay like 122
if you have any queries related to
python machine learning any problem in
this code
you can ask me in the comment section
okay we can just
we will respond you as soon as possible
okay I will get back to you when this
whole code will be done
whole process okay
so as you can see it's almost done 143
till 150
okay 144 six more
one more remaining
note the idle will not come after this
and the last one
okay so here we can start the model
evaluation so here for the result
equals to
model
dot evaluate
X test comma y
test
I
prediction equals to model
dot predict
s
test
so
after that I will let me
just to mean
salute
percentage
error
I test comma y
prediction
accuracy was you
1 minus
then
here I will write print
test loss
okay
comma result
and print
test map
and
test
accuracy
okay
accuracy is not defined
big deal maybe
okay
yeah
here
is small so that's why it's not loading
yeah so as you can see the test map is
0.02 and the accuracy is good like 97
percent
almost 98 percent
so let's visualize the results returning
the actual and predicted price values to
their primary scale okay so first
I will ship
this yeah so here I would like if I test
true let's go to scalar
dot inverse
transform
by test
then y test
prediction plus two scalar
dot inverse
transform
y prediction
okay now let's see investigate the
closeness of the prices predicted by the
model to the actual prices
okay for that here we have created the
kind of same kind of graph so I will
copy it from here
okay and paste it here
we'll do some color change
so instead of yellow I need this yarn
color
and model performance okay
that
I want the red okay
yeah
so let's see the actual
okay axis of Facebook C okay there is C
on and it's missing
so training data actual test data and
the predicted data okay so it's black
black
it's black black so what I will do I
will make it green
yeah
so training data is this and the actual
test data is this
and the predicted as it as this so it's
like predicting almost the same
so it means our LST model is performing
good within 97 accuracy
so as you can be seeing the price
predicted by the LST model like follows
the actual prices greatly the value of
loss and the accuracy of like 1 minus
map map obtained on the test data so
also confirm the great performance of
the model so loss equals is 0.001
accuracy is almost almost 98 percent
ok
so I hope you guys understand like how
you can do a model evaluation or time
series prediction gold price prediction
prediction using lstm model you can ask
in the comment section below if you have
any queries our team will respond to you
as soon as possible so don't forget to
check the courses or related to machine
learning AI from the description box
below and if you want this full code
if you want this full code just comment
for the same
and thank you so much for being here if
you enjoyed this video please subscribe
to our YouTube channel and give a like
to this video thank you and keep
learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here